hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to some of
you might find it very hard to believe
but I am an epoch I know I know
it said the true and I'm not always
proud of it but sometimes I'm proud
because there certainly films out there
that have it coming movies that so
obviously do not think at all about the
obvious flaws that most people would
find distracting but how far is too far
we've all come across those people who
let what seems like the tiniest of
errors ruin an entire film for them
these are the people you just want to
shout good god it's just a movie but
then ironically we go on and find our
own little pet peeves and movies that we
hate so then when is nitpicking
justified and when is it not because
when you look at anything close enough
you quickly discover that there really
is no such thing as a perfect movie
every film has some mistakes or some
miscalculations it's not surprising
seeing how film is an illusion and
whether it's telling a story or
performing a magic act at some point not
every trick is going to work some of the
most famous and loved films of all time
have huge mistakes in it for example in
star wars the destruction of the Death
Star is caused by sending one tiny
torpedo into a tiny little hole that
somehow blows up this entire base wait a
minute how can a little torpedo do that
why is it they have to do most of the
traveling in the trenches why don't they
just fly around space until they're
closer to that hole and then go way
closer why didn't the Empire just cover
that hole up to begin with they seem to
know to keep the rebels away from it why
did the Death Star just blow up the plan
to problem to destroy the rebel base
just like they showed on how it should
have ended all of these are major
problems with the climax but for the
most part nobody lets it bother Citizen
Kane said to be one of the best movies
of all time has a major mistake in it
the movie is about everyone trying to
figure out what Citizen Kane meant by
his last word
the problem nobody was there to hear him
say it yeah the room was empty when he
died so how does everyone know that's
the last thing he said putting this
whole journey into motion that's a huge
mistake and yet people still see it as
one of the standalone greats but still
how come in say an movie bowl film or an
M night Shyamalan film we're much more
open to criticizing these mistakes and
say that they've ruined the story they
were trying to tell is it just because
we don't like the movie and thus we look
for even more reasons to hate it well
kind of let's try to think about a movie
like The Wizard of Oz and how much many
people would attack it because well yeah
it's a kids movie
but not just because of that but because
it's a good kids movie a really good
kids movie yeah it's filled with things
that don't add up like why did Glenda
think Dorothy wouldn't believe her when
she said to click her heels or how could
the Wizard possibly project those
Holograms from that tiny machine or how
could the witch go all her life without
getting any water on her dude not even a
shower she must smell like rhino ass but
we still accept it for two reasons one
it created an environment where the
focus is on the emotions and not
illogical and - we're just so sucked in
by those emotions and the characters and
the visuals to really notice those
mistakes the same can be said for Edward
Scissorhands I rarely hear people ask
where the hell did you get those giant
blocks of ice from or even how an
inventor can make a man from scratch but
it's just the kind of fairytale world
it's creating and the hardened drama
Edward is so good that we don't feel the
need to question it then you start to
think about films like oh cool as ice
this is a film that does not draw you
into its characters for its environment
or its own unique work and because it
fails to keep our attention with these
elements it's much harder not to notice
the problems of the movie feeing
consistencies the mistakes the
nonsensical motivations so maybe when
we're nitpicking about the little
problems of a movie that we think add up
to big problems we're actually focusing
on the wrong
issue it's not that a movie has mistakes
it's that it failed to distract us from
those mistakes with good character story
and environment now that doesn't mean as
long as you have those three elements
you never have to worry about mistakes
film is still an illusion and one that
needs to hold the audience's attention
for a while the more plot holes or
inconsistencies of film has the more it
has to try even harder to create
engaging characters environments and
stories to distract you the goal is
still to convince the viewer that they
are witnessing a story that is unfolding
before their eyes so much so that they
carry investment for what happens in the
end so isn't it picking good nor bad
well it'll always be a fun pastime to
look behind the curtain and reveal the
wizard for the illusion as that he is
but the judgment on what we find depends
on whether or not he put on a good show
nitpicking leads to great comedy and
clever acknowledgement of how to make a
piece of art better but what should be
realized is that what we are nitpicking
is not the problem the problem is that
we're noticing yet at home I know many
people thought hard about the problems
in Star Wars after they first saw it but
after seeing it so many times that they
know the film inside and out then they
probably start to notice them more so it
all comes down to how much a movie can
grab you and keep you in its world the
better it's done the more you'll enjoy
the illusion and the world it's created
around you the more poorly it's done the
more likely you are to notice the
strings so keep nitpicking all you want
make jokes about it laugh at even get
angry if you feel it insults you enough
but remember that your anger doesn't lie
within the weak manipulation of the
facts as film is already a manipulation
your anger lies in not being given a
strong enough world people or dilemma to
get lost in so remember don't complain
in a puppet show that you can see the
puppeteer complain instead that you
focused more on him than you did the
puppet I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to